we already have a problem and it's
actually a shared problem
uh
that our nations have joined together in
the five eyes alliance which effectively
uh at least i don't know what else it
does but one of the things it does is it
allows
the united states canada
and the other members to
basically reciprocally violate the
rights of the citizens of the five eyes
in other words canada can you know the
united states government is limited in
how much spying it's allowed to do
against americans but it can contract
with canadians to do the spying and vice
versa um and so anyway we're kind of uh
we've
escaped the bounds that
uh were envisioned by the the authors of
these documents including you i think
yes i couldn't agree more i agree with
you 100 percent i would even enlarge it
the the nation state as we have
understood it is under vicious attack
right now and i believe in traveling
around the world and being involved in
elective office in canada that the the
the
the savior to mankind
and being
a democratic
organization
rests
on the shoulders of a nation state
what we have started to do in our
international agreements
like the eu started it years ago when
that was economic and then it became
political thank you for the brits to get
out of that bloody thing um and it was
only i think they had enough dna left
from the magna carta to stop doing this
and right i i was the ordinary person in
britain who stopped brex from being part
of the united kingdom it wasn't the
wasn't the leadership it was the farmer
who suddenly realized that brussels was
going to tell him how many bushels of
wheat he could grow next year that's
what really triggered what happened in
britain
but in any case
what's happening uh in the international
agreements now in trade agreements is
that they're infringing upon
the sovereignty of the united states of
america and the sovereignty of canada
that's where the line has to be drawn
that you do trade agreements and i'll
trade with you and you trade back with
me either by barter or whichever way you
want to do it but when you start to
interfere with the individual rights and
freedoms and the sovereignty of a nation
that the parliament of the united states
no longer has complete control over all
of its activity
that's where i draw the line and the
line has been crossed now i remember the
pacific partnership i think trump got
out of that and rightly so and rightly
so that's where every national
government should draw the line then
we'll do trade agreements because yeah
we've traded forever the greeks the
athenians were successful because they
manipula you know they managed to trade
with all of their partners in in the sea
in the mediterranean sea at the time
and so it goes back to the beginning of
man but that doesn't mean
that you can't have a trade agreement
and still have sovereignty you can have
both and that's the way it used to be
and now
the globalists starting out of europe
because they got their european union
still intact in some way or form
even though it's not it's pretty shaky
right now
we should not go down that road
the united states should remain a
national sovereign nation canada should
and we should then cooperate where we
can without interfering with our own
sovereignty i think this is really
the best explanation for what we're
seeing is that there is an unnamed
unelected unaccountable something
that finds the sovereignty of our
nations distinctly inconvenient and the
rights of the citizens to be
an ever-present thorn in the side
and it is now it has become impatient
and it used the pandemic and i must tell
you uh
i do think that this is a very dangerous
pathogen
a pathogen whose hazard is greater than
one can see in the case fatality rate um
and by virtue of the fact that it is
actually enhanced over what nature would
have delivered
but
but nonetheless it used the hazard of
that pathogen to get us to unhook
provisions of our constitutions that we
would never have unhooked under normal
circumstances and uh
you know really this couldn't be more
dangerous we will not get those rights
back if we do not defend them vigorously
and they you know
those of us who learned about this as it
unfolded are behind the eight ball right
the plan was pretty sophisticated and
highly successful before we even knew
what we were fighting about um so
it is time for us to wake up and defend
these documents
and what happens in canada and i'm sure
it does in the united states in general
jurisprudence here's what happens a case
comes before the court three years from
now in canada if we don't
restore
our charter and our bill to where it
really belongs so if we don't restore it
and get the courts to say no the charter
comes first the charter is in the
constitution by the way we have a thing
in our constitution which says the
constitution of canada is the supreme
law of camp
it oversees all
it's above all the other laws if we
don't overturn and have the judiciary
re-establish what will happen three
years from now or four years from now
when a citizen of canada goes to court
under their individual rights and
freedoms
the judge and the judiciary have the
license to say oh back in 2022 there was
a precedent set
and it's this precedent now that we must
go by and the charter is no more
right but somehow all of the things that
made this work
right are malfunctioning right so you
know we literally had the department of
homeland security
issue a bulletin
in which
they said
that mal information was a dangerous
type of terrorism and mal information
they defined in their document as based
on fact but causing people to distrust
the government right so the idea that we
cannot discuss facts like the corruption
of our government that would cause
people to be distrustful of it is a
violation of the most basic element of
our constitution and yet
you know as far as i know the aclu has
not immediately emerged to challenge
this i i hope i'm wrong about that but
it may be that the aclu is preoccupied
uh with the kind of nonsense that it's
been uh advancing in in recent years
and hasn't noticed this egregious
violation of our most basic right
exactly exact same kind of thing is
happening in canada exactly the same
kind of thing and uh the edicts come out
of the health departments and public
health officers uh you know out of some
obscure uh emergency
declared never defined right and that's
the other thing about it a lot of this
will not pass muster in any reasonable
um definition of emergency in canadian
law but the yet they declared one and
therefore because they've declared it it
is one without ever defining what the
emergency or the pandemic means
uh you know and
i've said now in my essay which i'll
publish today for example there was a
professor at simon fraser university in
vancouver
who in april 2021
released a report where he reviewed 80
studies from around the world
and demonstrated through those studies
that the cure was worse than the disease
the way they had approached the cure it
was worse than the disease and he
published that he could not get any of
the mainstream media to carry it
he went months and months without that
being carried by anybody and then now by
the way his document has been validated
over and over again very careful
and he took all these 80 studies and he
used all the different formulas that all
of the people like to use to define all
of this okay did it properly and by the
way in that study which is absolutely
damning because
the two court cases that i use in my um
essay to show that they violated okay
the constitution
these court cases came out in the late
fall
of 2021 october and november when his
report came out in april
so i'll come and and and one of the
courts was in british columbia two and a
half three miles as the bird flies from
his university
i mean you know i mean give me a break
so here you have and in that report by
the way he also said i also said that 90
days after
the virus was declared back in march
of 2020
there were
data available which he produced
which showed
that you stay on this present course of
that kind of mitigation and you're going
to be in deep deep trouble and so he
says there was even data available so
that the governments
in august of 2020 should have changed
course as to how they were mitigating
this virus and they did not and that
that was available right so this is the
the thing that i think has been driving
many of us crazy is that uh
what i noticed
geez i can't remember the first time it
occurred to me but
what we have in the u.s and i know that
you and canada have a mirror image of it
is
bad public health policy that exceeds
what what incompetence could have
generated in in other words if you look
at the policy uh that we have it is
actually the inverse of the correct
thing it is not it's not even random
it's far worse than that
but and then you see
a cost-benefit analysis like the one
you're describing and there is no
interest in looking at it because
apparently there is some other priority
driving the policy other than the desire
to limit the spread of the virus or
protect people's health
and guess what the headline of this
report was yes that cost benefit
analysis cost benefit analysis i mean
headline that's that's that's what he
headlined his report as
it makes sense and then of course you
know the the pattern is just utterly
reliable a cost-benefit analysis
suggests there's something wrong with
what we're doing and anybody who points
out that that's what a cost-benefit
analysis said is then demonized as if
they were unpatriotic or uncaring or
motivated by greed or who knows
and guess what in the interview that
i've done in the last four or five days
okay
most of them canadian okay by very well
known
smart
informed people uh and i mentioned doug
professor douglas allen of simon fraser
university it's the first time they
heard of it
even to this day because of course
nobody's carried
it's a little bit like the uh the
protests in in uh victoria that are
happening without uh
any any any awareness
yeah no it's a it's definitely a uh a
bizarre
moment and as much as we were thoroughly
warned by orwell and others
somehow no warning is sufficient until
you see it in real time
no and i i think it speaks to history
big time
i think it speaks to history big time
you know if you don't learn from history
you're bound to repeat it kind of stuff
you know
and we've seen this over the years with
the various wars and whatever through
all of our our our
history as a home as a as a species
right there's a homo sapien or whatever
you want to call us you see it over and
over again that's why victor david
hansen by the way who you quite might be
aware of in the united states who writes
um quite prolifically
on a lot of things he's a classic
scholar out of california and um but he
he he
he writes a lot in american greatness
and a couple of other websites
he just did a comparison with the uh the
degrees
and what's happening now and just you
know we're not learning from history
we're not learning from not only
yesterday but
you know lots of things which happen we
don't know our history we don't know
and we're not learning from it and so
we're very
as as a christian would say we're very
fallen angel don't we
well you know i i struggle there's a
certain penalty
that emerges if you
do draw
parallels to history
right you know you you can find yourself
in very hot water if you
uh draw these connections
and you know it strikes me as an
artificially high standard
right so okay we've got these vaccine
mandates it's not exactly
mangala it's not exactly tuskegee right
those are not perfect parallels but i
guess my point is at the moment that you
find yourself reaching for parallels and
those are your closest
your closest examples you are in very
dangerous water and so i don't know how
to make this point right why are we in
this section of the library looking for
analogies right right things are bad at
the point
that tuskegee becomes relevant to a
active public health program yeah um
yeah and you know like likewise the the
internment of japanese americans right
all of the relevant examples from
history are imperfect but that ought not
provide us comfort because the fact is
you know they're as close as we've got
yeah would you like to think that we
learn and that we will not
repeat
you know certain decisions which we know
were based upon data regardless of what
the nature of that data was whether it
was a virus or something else that we
won't then repeat it because we've had
knowledge
of how our imperfection
in another circumstance worked out but
we don't seem to be able to do a really
good job
on advancing so technically we've
advanced ourselves but i don't know does
anybody ever come along who can has the
same impact that the socrates or plato
or aristotle has had i mean where's our
montesquiou where's our political
philosopher of the 18th century where is
ours john stewartville i mean i don't
know if there anybody around where's our
francis bacon they're not versus cicero
and so i'm not so sure that uh on
a proper score of globally doing this
that we've advanced all that much as as
a
as a more well-rounded human being
yes uh that's true and
the other question is why do we not have
these figures and in part it may be
because to the extent that they exist
they've been so demonized and driven to
the fringe that we're not even aware of
them
good point um which is a tremendous very
sad a tremendous danger
um
all right is there anything else you
would like to cover before we wrap this
up no only that um and i keep arguing
and i know it's it's sort of a
i think a lot of us say but civil
disobedience is still
a very important
concept in any
sensible democracy any real democracy
that's why that thing in victoria is
very important and i keep saying that if
every legislature in canada every
saturday there were 10 000 plus people
on an ongoing basis over the next all
through the summer
that i think we could have an impact
upon public policy
[Music]